my name's Samuel Leeds and this week on
winners honor Wednesday I'm gonna be
interviewing somebody I met a couple of
years ago when I met this person he had
no money he was at university with lots
of debt he had no property experience
whatsoever and now fast forward just a
little over two years later he's
financially free he owns nine houses and
he'll never have to work a day in his
life unless he wants to please welcome
onto the show John ray bolt so how did
you get the property what happened and
how did it mess your life up well I got
into property January 2018 I came in
your crash course and open my eyes
completely I was a university student I
continue to be in versus student whilst
doing your academy and courses and
student history and politics at that
time I didn't really have a direction
and sort of go into your crash course
and get into property just completely
change my mind and my life really yes
completely my perspectives and
everything changed now you became
financially free within like six months
yes yes you came on winners Wednesday
yes but you've had so many you've grown
so much over the last of eight nine ten
months and event policies go wrong
yes tenants who are the worst kind of
tenants yes yes and you wanted to sort
of give an update as to the problems
that you've had the challenges that
you've had how you've overcame them how
you've grown and to give people a kind
of real balanced view completely yeah I
mean it's the theories they're the
theory behind sort of the property is
easy sometimes on the ground level you
can encounter problems it's how you get
over those problems what's the key
things I've had some seriously bad
tenants I've had issues with sort of
builders everything you can imagine that
I had but it's about getting over those
problems if a Japanese knotweed yep
you've had tenants not paying your bed
Terrance trusts in the house yep you've
had all cloner poles but the thing is I
think in your life you're always going
to have problems it's just a case of
having better kind of problems it's
about the mindset of how to get over
those problems I'd say people are always
gonna have problems doesn't matter what
area of property you're gonna you're in
what sort of tenants you dealing with
people will always have problems it's
how you think about getting over those
problems and staying positive and just
continue
pushing don't when you at university all
your university friends presumably their
problems is stuff like i need to advise
for this exam or I'm running late for
you my class yeah on board or I need to
figure out what I'm gonna do my future
that's their problems your problems are
so Japanese knotweed in my investment
property yes that is not a typical
problem for how old are you
well I was at university I was
twenty-one twenty-two at that point so
you're 29 23 May 23 I guess so we've
been working together for like two years
yes so what I want is I want to get big
picture about how you became financially
free to property you have we have doing
a video on that before so yes you want
to see that just check the link list
above but just give us a bit a big
picture how much money did you have when
you started so when I started obviously
as university I had my student loan
which is to support me through
university but I didn't have any other
savings or anything like that
I had to network and use people within
my network within within my networking
sort of their networks to bring in
investment money and did you use your
student to invest involved
I used well to start off to get into the
Academy I put some of my student money
down as a deposit because I was 100%
convinced that I wanted to be in this
and I wanted to you know press forward
at this and then I found the rest of the
Academy money through so investors can
we not do that some people would say
don't let people go into debt and
university students use all that student
debt to go on my training programs
because that's being like irresponsible
but I've seen so many people like you
that have done that actually
irresponsible is going what did you
study history and politics how's that
going to help you I thought that when I
was doing it I like that's irresponsible
how much did that cost you that
university program so it's 9,000 pound a
year times 3 so 2007-2008 spending 27
grand to study history help me out now I
mean I enjoyed it but I did see the
point I did see once I was in property I
did see that it wasn't gonna be my
future it was my mom who wants me to
finish the final year and I was like I
don't even what you fish yeah you did
say stop it I was like I'll do if my mom
I'll get it finished
I guess yeah vlogging over a dead horse
but so many people go to university to
please their parents yeah I see the
thing is I I don't really settle my
other self my company I was into
property I was doing what I wanted but I
knew all to make my mom proud as well
and I knew I could do that on the side
with university so just like bit sword
I'm free alright so you chose to spend
twenty seven thousand pounds and three
years of your life doing something to
make you more happy
fine but at least you you were smart
enough to also sell property business
and do that are you ever gonna ever have
a job in your life no I'll never have to
work under someone else now I'll always
personally myself I'll always be in
property and I'll always be my own boss
yeah and of course you know you might
have to work because you might have to
manage your property especially if
you're of course yes yes there's always
always a sense of work being a business
owner but you'll never never be
controlled by anybody else because the
main thing you were like I wanted you
HMOs you went on to the advanced
training you learn the skills had no
money within it some I seriously helped
you with some of those calls yes so
helping me raise finance and stuff yeah
when we had our one-to-one you helped me
you suck me down we went through my
phone and you basically saw how awkward
conversation yeah and don't know if we
talked about like the first one was
Wednesday but like you were phoning
people the new family friends Network
whatever and I was telling you what to
say and you were like pressing me I was
telling you and then you were only and
he was saying it they're responding this
how happens right
I'm within within like minutes you
raised how much money so we raised we
raised a half now we raised four hundred
thousand but this and you're not from a
big wealthy background now rounded by
kings and princes and stuff no no it's
it's just basically tappings of people
who I didn't even know would be
interesting this kind of thing as soon
as I said I'm interested in it yes they
wanted to help me obviously help
themselves as well they wanted to help
push me forward that's incredible
okay so you raised some finance and by
the way anyone that's thinking oh I
couldn't raise finance like there is so
much money in people's banks when you
have the skill to be able to invest that
money
as long as you can offer them better
than the bank and often awesome it's
safe something good a job venture or a
fixed interest I mean come on it's just
what would you think I mean I'm already
at this point most people watching this
who are your age will be thinking oh I
could never raise four hundred thousand
you don't have to raise four hundred you
can raise forty thousand people who say
they'll never do it will never do it
you've got two of the minds it's got to
be open to it you've got have the minds
of I will do this that's what I always
think so I will raise fine I said matter
how much I will raise finance and when
you've got that kind of mindset you will
you will succeed in it so there's plenty
of other people in the Academy like
Anthony John you've got that mindset I
will do something and they do it because
of that exactly if you have the mindset
and the scale yeah the training and the
ability to take massive action together
with persistence and self belief and
support like how can you not felt
history studying 21 22 year old own
money flat broke suddenly you got money
awesome then what happened so then I
always had to find the property deal so
I wanted so I located a couple of
property deals got offers in and we set
off with our first first HMO yeah from
there obviously this redevelopment it
very development needed but once the
first one was up and running that gave
me the confidence just keep going so
we've got we've got a both mostly yes so
I've got 6 H M O's yeah and there's two
single that's as well cuz I mainly focus
on HMOs yeah because the single let's
not make you yes there's not not massive
massive problematic HMOs HMOs generally
depend on the number of people in them
bigger ones I'm looking about a thousand
pound minimum profit smaller ones I'm
looking maybe five hundred pounds profit
so across the board oh yeah yeah so
about four four five grand immense
profits what's been brought in yet so
and you've done that we've raised
violence you've done that in joint
ventures yes I know you've pulled your
dad in as well yes I pulled my dad
obviously to one of those yeah so you
helped him though obviously took him to
your crash course I dragged him to one
lay it down the line got him on board
and then obviously we start a company up
together and we just father so good so
good and I think if you can do that if
you can persuade your it's hard to
persuade your parents and what I say to
young folks is don't try and persuade
them
let me persuade them yeah you bring them
to a crash course and watch what happens
no my dad my dad has been obviously
amazing and very supportive with it and
it's good to have someone there you know
when you're having a negative day
they'll pick you up
I'm like he's having a negative day oh
nice guy but he when I first met he was
the biggest skeptic or negative surely
it won't work yes to start with yeah
but bringing him to the crash course
completely changed him open his eyes to
what could be done and from sort of that
moment that sort of inspirational moment
we've worked together and we've ploughed
on with the property and when we've hit
problems we've just looked at right
problem how did we get around this why
did you choose the strategy out of
interest because one of the reasons I
mean you've had all kinds of problems
but and a problem is just an opportunity
to learn that's just a challenge yeah
it's a challenge to get over it yeah
it's I saw a video I think it was one of
the Academy members - humming video of
the CCTV we've some of your tenants in
the kitchen and they were like throwing
chairs around and watching me and I was
horrified yep so I mean with regards to
some of the HMOs we were having a couple
of the HMOs will have benefit Tennessee
when we were having very bad issues of
behavior and stuff so there's ways to
get around that and one of the solutions
was well let's install CCTV in the
communal areas and I get around the
problem ones that goes mean you can
watch it that well to a degree it can't
it down there were instances like that I
always saw but that and that whilst us
also meant that for instance if it's
people coming into the house my friends
and tenants and they're causing issues
we can prosecute them because so we've
got some people getting done on criminal
charges for smashing things this life
though this landlord life that you have
like oh you know I invest in properties
and get professional terms that's more
model you have gone down a different
model which does create problems for
sure mmm do you regret or do you think
over what are you glad you did that I
mean I've got I've got HMOs there's
professional tenants and I've got HMOs
we're sort benefit tenants
there's pros and cons to both Theory the
pros and cons so pros and cons for
benefit tenants are also you can get
cheaper houses the houses don't have to
be a
immaculate as if you're dealing with
professional tenants so you know it
doesn't everything doesn't have to be
really well painted really nice it's
it's more functional everything's cheap
but then she your day with cheap tenants
yeah cheap and functional that's
obviously a big benefit you don't have
to have to put as much money in the
house the cheaper so it's a cheaper
start off there is then the issues with
obviously tenants which is negative so
some some tenants can't lump everyone
together some tenants can have issues
paying you that has happily canceled the
pay direct no so with the way Universal
Credit works and generally the universal
credit is paid the first payment is paid
direct at the tenant and then once that
if the tenant for instance doesn't pay
me pay me the rent I can then forward to
the council with a you c-47 claim for
the rent to be paid direct to me once
all the rents in a house we paid direct
to direct the landlord direct to me
you're laughing because you're getting
all the money indirect then you laughing
financially but then you've still got
protection and damaging the property the
problem the thing is not all tenants are
good not all benefit tenants you know
are bad though so some of them you've
got some this one's not very nice guys
who live in my properties but there are
some more challenging and difficult
tenants yes the thing is once you once
you find out with the challenging
difficult tenants are you just have to
you know you have to work from there you
intentionally get rid of the potentially
try and work with them saying look you
can't behave like this give them
warnings just go away do you manage the
tenants yourself you have a management
company how does that work so what
what's happened is I do have a
management company for all my hedge Mo's
but we've had such serious problems in a
couple of the larger HMOs to start with
that I helped out with live for instance
going around and checking stuff and from
from a sort of another perspective I'm
actually interested in this or how
everything works the lettings and stuff
so from a perspective of like growing
and learning it's actually very useful
to go around and deal with sunset also
John you love the psychology but alright
yeah I've still not work some of them
are you sick they would mean you like
trying to figure them out and trying to
work out why they do that how can I have
a vision for a test understand why
tenants do a certain thing oh yeah yeah
definitely yes in some ways yes II saw I
don't sign up for that
what is this class for me I'd rather
deal with professional tenants reference
them well may get credit checks
references and high end but I know a lot
of people people on the Academy like
yourself who were doing to go down that
route and they're killing it and if
everybody did the same thing if everyone
just said professional only then
suddenly will went what about what about
laj tenants of course yeah I mean
someone has to do it I'm just glad that
it's you and not me it's just an area
I've sort of gone down will I continue
going down it for many years I don't
know but I've tried jobs II tried
professional tenants I've got certain
HMOs with professional tenants they go
well yeah I've not had serious problems
with their the tenants all been fine so
do you think you could just like
absolutely kill it with this strategy
this LHI HMOs violent cheap
functional put the tenants in wait for
the tends to miss a payment and then get
the council to pay direct keep an eye on
them keep close to them how CCTV there
just could that be your big thing
potentially yeah I mean this this the
thing is there's you never there's so
many people who are in that sort of
position you know on the benefits and
that kind of things not many landlords
cater towards that noise so I thought if
office lis I do cater towards them I'm
not you know there's so many tenants are
so much choice and demand there I can
potentially like maybe reference them a
bit better but and try it always have
people in there I never have void
periods and you make good money yeah
definitely making good money from it
it's it's just it's just partly game
your life is not like the average 23
year old life oh definitely not
definitely not making good money
managing really difficult tenants so
talking about some of the other problems
you've had talk to me about some of the
property owners bill roads and the
houses so we've had we've had issues
with builders so for example was on a
single at properties when we were trying
to get that renovated me mud it was a
project with me my dad me my dad my dad
more decided to use a family friend to
try and do the building work and try and
sort everything out like the kitchen and
stuff but this is the problem with sort
of dealing with people sometimes we were
very close to you you can't you just
want to mess with the friendship and
when obviously this guy wasn't doing the
work properly and getting it all sorted
on time and
stuff was taking longer they couldn't
really do anything so eventually we
learn from that that we have to use sort
of external more external people who you
know we sort of have legitimate
contracts with get everything sword yeah
because when you almost feel like
someone's be a bit of a favor yeah and
then you better off to just pay what's
what's needed and completely completely
yeah so yeah basically we've looked
obviously we've learned that we've
learned to do everything properly
you know actually get good builders in
get good contracts set with them and
then just progress it's not always best
to work with the people who become
become workout unbalanced but we found
that we we did have issues with the guy
when he was obviously to work so we
build us as a how do you how do you find
and liaise with good builders
so generally obviously you go I would
say ask to look at previous work that
they've done mmm if you can look at that
and you you know if you go look at the
previous where they've done you're happy
with that sort standard then that might
be a good builder for you obviously if
you've got a builder if you go talk to
builder and the Builder you know you say
I've got a project he says yeah I can do
it yes it's Friday evening he says yeah
I can do it Monday if he's not got a lot
of work on so potentially that might
mean he's not in high demand he might
not be that good look at it perspective
look at it from the perspective of if a
builder says well I can do you in two
weeks mate that might mean that
obviously a lot of people are using him
he is skilled he is good at what he does
yeah professional he might with saw a
guy great good so look at their previous
work make sure that they're not
desperate yeah the same time you don't
want that some builders are are doing
six months ago you probably you can't
work with that but you do balance do you
use building teams or do you use one-man
bounds or does it depend on the project
depends on the project completely
depends on the project I have used like
sort of one-man bands IV I have used
building teams I've used so you know
sort out the separate trades myself
sometimes but I would always say having
a building team is the best way to go so
talk to me about the big Japanese
knotweed talk to me about that because
that's something that's very taboo
everyone's scared of it firstly tell us
one
so it's an invasive species which
obviously you can have if it grows in
your land all around your properties it
kind of issues getting mortgages 3
mortgages on the property right yes
you can't even I mean I've had I've had
property for Japanese knotweed and you
can't even take it to the tip oh no no
you can't you can't do it's not treated
yeah it's like very because it grows
through concrete oh yeah I literally
bring down a castle it can bring yeah
yeah of course
I've got it it's all sorted we knew we
knew we knew beforehand that there was
Japanese knotweed so when your house did
you know or was it surprise it was well
it's an unfortunate surprise really that
is not good no I know it's not at all
but we've we've got it treated and we'll
work well as you've been working the
treatment we'll get we'll get it sold
and the city cost to go treated it's
about five five thousand I think it's
only sort of a smallish area but we
didn't want to leave it and let it till
you bought this house and did you think
oh my gosh the house is so cheap
I can't believe I've got such a good
purchase and then you read oh oh yeah
yes so we've basically been refurbished
just about finished refurb in it and
then it was what's that small weed lots
of it didn't look good and I don't
obviously got it checked out with a
professional came round and he said yeah
you've got Japanese knotweed only in a
very small area but you've got to treat
a sort of wider area around it yeah that
can be devastating I mean you were kind
of fortunate yes yeah five grand is not
I mean that can just mean your house is
0-2 it's valued at zero yeah you can't
be serious promises you know like get a
service before you bought it I think was
it wasn't it's as if obviously when we
bought the house I'd looked in the
garden myself surveyor would come round
they'd looked in the garden there's
nothing there
it's as if obviously when we had start
the building work that kind of thing and
would nearly finished it's as if we
disturbed the ground and then it started
grow how do you stop that happening how
do you make sure that you do not have
Japanese knotweed before you buy a house
I would say it's difficult I would say
surveys are a key to it and obviously
your own personal vision going around do
it during viewings but I would say it
can occasionally happen to anyone
maybe ask neighbors if very lucky very
lucky normally
if there's Japanese knotweed it'll be on
the description because the estate agent
has to say it then if the stage it
misses it the survey should definitely
pick it up for it to be that hidden oh
yeah I mean it's sometimes it's disturb
some times if the ground is disturbed
through building work can that you
consult I stay hidden like yes if it was
bad Japanese knotweed the severe would
see it oh yeah it was bad Japanese
knotweed it's a very to see it and you
know and you'd be informed and
everything to be fine you know we'd
progress accordingly book because it was
only a little patch I suppose it kind of
got missed no tell me what average day
for John rabe or looks like and also
doesn't about the relationship for main
you've become very much part of the
inner circle within the Academy made a
lot of friends yeah something about like
an average day in their life of John so
generally what I'll do is I'll Bob Leo's
with I get up early I have to get up
early because obviously you've got to
make the most you day even though I
don't even though I don't have a full
you know I don't have a job I have to
get up to you have to be an entrepreneur
I have to maximize my time so I'll
liaise with a state early age with the
state agents if I'm looking for deals so
I'll be looking for deals constantly
potentially to sell on or potentially
for myself to work with I'll be talking
to a stick talking to the letting agents
making sure money's come in transactions
everything like that I've been making
sure that the properties are all sort of
maintained it's also be talking to the
Layton agents in that sense and
basically just keeping everything under
control
potentially if this building work going
on I'll be liaising with this or
building team find out everything if
everything's working working smoothly
going well so just sorting everything
out really just being a proper
entrepreneur so you're like real
hands-on in property yes yeah I would
but I think passive income exists I
would say passive income that you've all
if you're a business owner you've always
got to have your eye on the ball ball
passive income does exist I'm just
wanting to grow my business faster and
so because I'm obviously very hands-on
in that sense more you have to grow
things as fast as I can because I guess
if you wanted to if you're making four
five grand a month you could probably
pay someone to grand a month
to replace you and you literally do
nothing and just make a couple grand a
month and that would be completely
passive but you'd rather you thinking
I'm gonna push this I'm gonna grow I'm
gonna learn course I'm only young mean
I'm only 23 yeah I want to grow on to
learn I want to expand things and
obviously there would be the option yet
to pay someone to grand a month and then
do it
I wouldn't grow ass or stagnate as a
person and obviously that's not what I
want to do I want to keep my business
growing and potentially go into other
areas yeah I've got to keep going keep
everything than my own control so you
had a lot of problems you've had
challenges big picture how things
looking I mean obviously everyone's
gonna have challenges big picture
everything's going great we've got over
the problems and that is the key thing
everyone will have problems everyone
will have challenges and I like to see
them as challenges but it's getting over
them we've got over most of ours and
from that sort of perspective now we're
on about five thousand six thousand
pound a month profit mmm you know it's
everything is going well financially
obviously I can't thank you enough for
all the train and everything like that
you've given me and helped me to
progress with this but yeah everything
everything everything is looking rosy
now it's just we went to a bit of a
problem patch of course problems of
course well yeah about because I
appreciate you you know saying about the
training and that that's what we do we
help people be Tennessee investors how
would how could life have been if you'd
have had all the problems without the
training knowledge support without the
training knowledge support I wouldn't
have actually got into property but if
for instance I had got into property and
I had hit these kind of problems I would
have just been stumped I wouldn't have
had their the mines I would have been
given the mindset to know how to push
through and get over problems to find
solutions I wouldn't a lot of it
obviously there's the training was
learning but a lot of it is the mindset
and once you once you've got that
mindset and I obviously got the mindset
through training seeing other people who
were like doing well and wanting to be
like them once you've got that kind of
mindset to get over problems you flying
also I think environment and friendships
like if you are on your own and you
don't have friends who are property
investors and you've got all these
problems it's like what the heck do I do
with this because your friends at
University presumably not many of them
in problems oh no no I mean there
interested in what I was doing to a
degree but I couldn't really talk to
them about a property issue or anything
like that so it was important to have
networks of people who are actually
interested in the same thing in property
who obviously I met I met people in the
Academy I met people at other networking
events it's important to have like a
circle of people you can talk to about
your property issues and sort of resolve
them together as a team kind of thing
sometimes yeah for sure because because
and then you can share your burdens of
people oh yeah you might be having
problems with you have loads of funds
and loads of properties and loads of
tenants but use tribute to my
lieutenants someone else might have a
problem that they've only got one house
and they want more tenants yeah you say
let's share each other's burdens
oh of course yeah JV how [ __ ] of the
rally and that's I think that's also
really important so what what's next in
what was the one of the next sort of six
twelve months look like year so
continuing to sort of continue to build
the property portfolio really continuing
to get more houses redevelop them into
HMOs that is my main strategy and that's
what I want to do gonna keep doing that
for maybe six to twelve months at least
and then from there I'm not 100% sure I
might look into going into more sort of
development that kind of thing but
basically I've got sort of the cash flow
I've got a steady business so I can look
into whatever I want to do how many
times have you been to a crash course
I've been probably about fifteen times I
sort of know all the different sections
I know you're gonna say next basically
time yeah to the property investors
crash course yeah you said the song that
was thinking about ending the property
message crash course definitely I would
say go 100 percent go give you good
insight a good basic insight into
property and how to start it's obviously
a very easel enthusiastic room and it
gives you a lot of very good information
at a hundred percent say go why do you
why do you be in fifteen times I'm gonna
show you becoming again soon of course
so obviously I what I went once myself
obviously experienced it and signed up
for the Academy and everything like that
I went once and took my dad and then all
the other times have been interesting
going both to pick things up again
or potentially might missed it's always
useful bits of information coming in but
also to help other people who looking at
get into their property journeys and
saying look I've managed to succeed in
doing it this is what I did and
obviously try and give back to
really yeah I mean a 23 year old
financially free in property it's kind
of rare and also when every time you
come on how you bring people with you
and you're breaking along but then
they're they can then end up joint
venturing with you oh yeah the more
people are aware of how to invest in
property and how to make money and learn
the skills actually it just creates a
bigger group of people that you can then
do deals with collaborate with share
problems with because I think a lot of
people feel very competitive they're
like sometimes even want success
students they'll become successful and
then they'll almost say just operate in
the crash courses now yeah it's like
they're successful because they came to
the crash course and now it's like it's
not running them now but it's let's keep
doing it I want to help yeah obviously I
want to try and help other people and
support other people in sort of
developing their their own property
journeys because I couldn't have done it
without support from you know support
from you and support from other members
your staff and stuff like that so I want
to try and give back to them since their
start and grow that's great man so what
would be your biggest to kind of wrap up
biggest piece of advice to someone
watching this maybe they're like John
Raybould was two years ago three years
ago University no money student there no
property knowledge no one in your family
that's supporting you and wanting you to
do property you weren't from there to
like up here first pieces of advice
basically you got to do whatever it
takes I say educate yourself and once
you've got that level of education
you've just got to push through whatever
problems you hit you've got to go over
them do whatever it takes and you will
be successful I would say I love it
whatever it takes I love that do
whatever tastes and those people say to
me say me when's the next crash course
in Newcastle I'm like good news we're
running one in Birmingham next month
it's a bit far I'll wait for one a bit
closer it's like if you're so stoppable
that you can't travel for hours when
people are coming from all over the
world
if you're that stoppable you're never
going to be successful
anyway of course the young man's will
not come yeah of course you know because
you got it like you see you gotta be
someone who when there's an obstacle you
walk around it yeah you got to find a
way oh I'm done now you got to find a
way to get over that obstacle
yeah just I've got no money I can't get
a mortgage I can't get to the
of course I can't I can't finally deals
I've got bad chemicals I've got or find
this solution which people find
solutions poor people find problems of
course they do I mean I've had plenty of
problems but I view them as challenges
yeah and you get over challenges
obviously some people are very stoppable
and they'll hit problems and they sort
of give up you cut if you want to if you
want to grow if you want to be wealthy
and you want sort of them sort of a cash
flow rich life you can't fall to stop
the problems now get over the problem
yeah that's what you have to do voice be
wealthy and solve problems hundred
percent love it who's winners Wednesday
story have you enjoyed or was inspired
you the most in the past so I mean I've
loved obviously all of them I thought
Anthony's was really really inspiring
sort of his his sort of like pushing
forward the kind of attitude his sort of
attitude to get over problems and just
really do whatever it takes I thought
his was really really inspiring and
really amazing you just heard it from
John if you want to watch Anthony John
Wilmots winners on the Wednesday episode
it is very fun I'm gonna go you can
check that out it is right here
also if you've got to come on to the
property investors crash course two days
absolutely free you can do that right
here and also don't forget to subscribe
down over here